this is a national emergency
our work here will ensure a peace
mankind has never seen
the world will remember this day
[Applause]
this is arguably the most important
story of our time the stakes really
couldn't be any higher it's profound but
it's told in a very human way everything
Chris Nolan has done has been a Prelude
to this this is not a film this is an
experience it is a heart in your mouth
Thriller
I've been interested in oppenheimer's
story for a long time at some point I
learned this key piece of information
that in the lead up to the Trinity test
they were dealing with the very small
possibility that when they push that
button they would set fire to the
atmosphere of the earth and destroy the
entire planet and yet they push that
button
I wanted to take the audience into that
extraordinary moment in human history
one zero
[Music]
all America's industrial mited
scientific innovation connected here
secret Laboratory
Killian playing Oppenheimer was the
centerpiece of the film but I knew that
he was going to need the most
extraordinary Ensemble around it let's
go recruit some scientists the people
involved in the Manhattan Project were
charismatic individuals they're very
talented the world that Oppenheimer
inhabits is filled with rock star
scientists and and I think because we
have all these fantastic actors you
really buy that
it felt like I was playing sports with
some of the best athletes every single
person has come to set knowing that they
have been hired because somewhere along
the line Chris thought that you did a
good job and this goes for crew as well
my preference is to always do things in
camera as much as possible it sets a big
challenge for every Department to
actually bring the reality of a thing
there for the actors every crew member
on this film has to adjust their work
for the iMac screen iMacs can contain
18K resolution per frame which is by far
more than any digital camera it gets
thrown up on a gigantic screen and the
moment you watch it it's very evident
the quality is unprecedented this is the
story of America in the 20th century so
I think it can be painted on that big of
canvas and what better way to do that
but with IMAX cameras why would we go to
the middle of nowhere for who knows how
long I always try to use real locations
as much as possible with location
shooting or sets the more things can
just be real the better they're going to
feel to the audience there's almost no
Studio work on this film everything is
location
the sets were built in such a way that
they felt incredibly authentic
we built Arlo's Alamos at Ghost Ranch
New Mexico which is along the same
mountain range that Los Alamos proper
sits on this was very important and I
based all of this on Research we built
all of these buildings 360. we want it
to feel like you are right there you are
in this this is happening this is real
this isn't a Backlot it's just the most
transporting thing you know when you're
there and it just looks exactly like Los
Alamos 1940s must have looked and you
know that no detail has been overlooked
you know we've also shot in a huge
amount of the real locations we shot in
our Panama's house in Los Alamos we shot
in Princeton
walking through Princeton it's really
very funny because people you know
they're walking around
shooting those scenes playing the
characters who really had versions of
these events happen there you just get a
real charge out of it you know
this is a matter of life and death
but I can perform this miracle when you
do Chris's movies things that when you
read a script you normally would think
would be visual effects you know that
you're going to be doing the stuff
practically
they had to film the world of quantum
physics their whole unit was one big
science project I was daily very jealous
the old days we did a lot of
experimentation we came up with some
very interesting analog methods of how
to approach this all of which was
leading to the Trinity test which had to
feel nightmarish and terrifying in a way
that computer Graphics never really is
what we were able to get into the
finished film to me is extraordinarily
beautiful but also very frightening
working with this whole team was such a
great camaraderie and with the
commonality of we are going to get this
in camera I love Chris's dedication to
that it really speaks to Chris and the
way he directs all of the energy goes
around the camera like we're all here to
do the same thing Chris makes films for
theaters for a movie going audiences you
know so you want to see that as it's
designed to be seen
watching this very different sort of
film on that big screen it sort of makes
you gasp you're right in their
experience this
this is I think a definitive moment in
the history of modern filmmaking do
yourself a favor and go see this on as
big a screen as you can with the sound
design and the score and the
emotionality of it this is an
unforgettable unmissable experience in a
theater you are the man who gave them
the power to destroy themselves we've
made Oppenheimer on the larger scale
possible because the idea is to come and
experience this his story is Monumental
and epic and extraordinary it really has
to be seen on the big screen to be
believed
[Music]